let's say that this right over here is
the graph of lowercase
f of x that's lowercase f of x there
and let's say that we have some other
function capital f of x
and if you were to take its derivative
so capital f prime of x
that's equal to lowercase f of x
lowercase f x
so given that
which of these
which of these could be the graph of
capital
of capital f of x and i encourage you to
pause this video and try to think about
it on your own before we work through it
well if if this curve is going to be the
derivative of one of them that means
that any for any x value it's describing
what the instantaneous rate of change or
what the slope of the tangent line is of
whichever one of these is the possible
capital f of x
so let's just look at a couple of things
about here so what do we know about
lowercase f of x what do we know which
is the derivative of one of these
well one thing we know is it's always
positive it has as we go to negative
infinity it asymptotes towards zero but
it's always positive so since this is
describing the slope of one of these
that means that the slope of one of
these all or out of the candidates has
to always be positive
and if we look at this the slope of the
tangent line here is indeed always
positive slope of the tangent line here
does look like it's positive every time
we increase in x we're increasing by y
here it's positive but here it's
negative when we increase by x we
decrease by y so we can rule
we can rule this one out
now what else what else do we know
well this is the derivative this is
telling us the slope of the tangent line
so for example when x is equal to
when x is equal to negative four
f of
f of negative four is pretty close to
zero
it's pretty close to zero so it's
slightly slightly more than zero
so that tells us that the slope of the
tangent line of capital f of x
has to be pretty close to zero
when x is equal to negative four
so let's see when x is equal to negative
four here this slope the slope of the
tangent line here isn't close to zero
this actually looks closer to one so we
could rule this one out
over here when x is equal to negative 4
the slope of the tangent line yeah that
actually does look pretty close to 0. so
i won't rule that one out
and over here the slope of the tangent
line when x is equal to negative 4 that
also looks
pretty close to 0. so these are still
both in the running
so let's see how we can think of a
difference so let's just pick another
point when x is equal to
when x is equal to zero f of zero looks
like it's pretty
close to one i don't know if it's
exactly the one actually it looks almost
exactly
almost exactly equal to one
so when capital f of
so at capital f of zero the slope of the
tangent line used to be pretty close to
one
so over here the slope of the tangent
line when x is equal to zero
that looks smaller than one so this
slope is definitely
not one while over here when x is equal
to zero
the slope of the tangent line
does look the slope of the tangent line
does look pretty
pretty close
pretty close to 1.
so this right over here looks like the
best candidate for capital
for capital f of x so that one right
over there let me that is
capital f of x and you might see hey
these look very similar to each other in
fact they look almost or actually they
do look identical and you might remember
from what you knew about differentiation
and actually these both look like the
basic exponential function where i
didn't ask you to figure out what the
actual function was just what the
possible anti-derivative of this
function would be this is the derivat
lowercase f is the cat is the derivative
of capital f or you could say that
capital f is an antiderivative
of lowercase f and when you just inspect
this this looks like this the function
both of these functions is our e to the
x because the derivative of e to the x
is
e
to the x